i was looking at behind the scenes
photos from the filming of better call
saul season six and while i was in my
screenshots folder i came across this
guy's mustache
when he popped up in season five he
looked very familiar
where had i seen that mustache before
hey guys pete here i've been wanting to
do some better call solve videos while
waiting for season six to finally arrive
and the mustachioed man gave me an idea
in this video i'm going to recap every
breaking bad character that appeared in
the prequel series
this will involve some spoilers if you
haven't watched both series
and with that warning out of the way
let's get straight to it
obviously as a prequel the main
characters from better call saul
were first introduced in breaking bad
jimmy mcgill
slash saul goodman slash gene takavic
first appeared in season 2 episode 8 of
breaking bad which had the fitting title
a better call saul
i don't want to spend too much time on
these guys but there is an interesting
story about the introduction of our next
main character
mike ermentrout in 2015 bob odenkirk
told rolling stone
i promise you i thought i was up for
three episodes of breaking bad
well they wanted me for four but i could
only do three because i was in how i met
your mother
they actually added the character of
mike because i couldn't make that fourth
week and they needed another character
to get that information across
so when mike made his debut in episode
13 of season 2
that scene was originally supposed to be
saul and now we all have how i met your
mother to thank for the birth of the fan
favorite
character gus fring rounds out the trio
of main crossover characters
he first appeared in breaking bad in
season 2 episode 11 which has an
interesting title
mandala this is the sanskrit word for
circle and the episode opens with the
death of combo
and ends with skylar going into labor
with holly
the circle of life indeed and there's an
interesting story about gus showing up
and better call saul
gus's first appearance wasn't until
season 3 episode 2. but the writers
planted a clue in the previous one that
they thought
fans might discover in the offseason if
you look at the first letters of the
episode titles from that season they
spell out
frings back what's funny here is that as
soon as the title of the final episode
was announced
fans figured it out like right away that
left vince gilligan and peter gould
worried that there would be
disappointment
considering gus doesn't appear on screen
in the season 2 finale
that led to them confirming that he was
behind the note that was left in mike's
car
which set the stage for him to enter the
story in season
three for me the first big surprise
character to show up in season one
was tuko salamanca tuko first appeared
in the sixth episode of the first season
of breaking bad
and was a scene stealer given his
explosive personality
wound tight would probably be an
understatement
ah tight tight yeah
would probably be more accurate tuko
exited bcs
after nacho and mike work together to
set him up that encounter landed him in
los lunas prison
where he'll share a cell with skinny
pete setting up his future connection
with walt and jesse
with tuko we get two other characters
along for the ride nodoz and gonzo
both appeared for the first time in
season 1 episode 6 of breaking bad
and season 1 episode 2 of the prequel
these guys were soldiers
nodos paid the price for speaking out a
turn during a deal with walt and jesse
and gonzo's dying in the process of
trying to go back and move that body
is what put tuko on the run from the dea
and hank schrader
those two will face off later where hank
ends tuko's story
my favorite character cameos are the
secondary characters that are sometimes
easy to miss
and usually require the internet hive
mind to discover
this unnamed nurse from bcs season 1
episode 5 is one of those
we see her run into chuck's hospital
room to try to stop
jimmy who's trying to turn off
everything that runs on electricity
her brief appearance in breaking bad
season 4 episode 12 is sort of similar
and that she runs out of brock's
hospital room to try to stop jessie
from entering the final two characters
to appear in the first season of bcs
are stacy and kaylee ermentrout they're
both a big part of mike's story and
there's some weirdness here
because stacy was played by a different
actor when she showed up in breaking bad
season 3 episode 13.
she doesn't have a speaking part and was
uncredited for her wave to mike
haley shows up a lot more in the
original series first in the second
episode of the
third season but there's weirdness with
her and her
ages the ages of the actresses that play
her things don't exactly add up
and the writers have admitted that it's
an inconsistency
in the opening episode of season two of
better call saul
we get the return of ken wins ken was
the douchebag with the bluetooth
phone earpiece that put himself on
walt's radar when he snaked his parking
space at the bank
later in that same episode walt gets his
revenge by blowing up
ken's car at a gas station and in bcs
jimmy and kim playing victor with a k in
giselle
scam him out of a bottle of zafiro anejo
tequila
hector salamanca first appeared in
breaking bad season 2
episode 2 in that period of time when
tuko was on the run
as his uncle at first we only knew him
as tio
we get to see him before he was confined
to the wheelchair
for the first time in the fifth episode
of better call saul's second season
there is a flashback where we see a
younger hector in breaking bad
but we see him in the present timeline
of bcs
over the seasons we get a better
understanding of his rivalry with gus
and how enough hatred had formed to set
up him taking them both out with a bang
quite literally in their final scenes
the salamanca twins marco and leonel
also made their better call saw debut in
season two
in the sixth episode they arrive on the
scene and hauntingly threaten
mike and kaylee from a nearby rooftop
while she's in the pool
the twins first appeared in breaking bad
in the premiere
episode of season 3 and what else can
you say
these guys know how to make an entrance
for that matter
marco's final scene in the seventh
episode of the same
season is one of the most memorable exit
scenes in the entire
series crazy 8 who first appeared in the
breaking bad pilot and has the
distinction of being the first character
walter white killed with his bare hands
made his first bcs appearance in season
2
episode 4. later in the fifth season we
learned how he earned his nickname
in a poker game with lalo salamanca
in that same episode that crazy 8
returns
the gun dealer lawson makes an
appearance when mike goes looking for a
rifle
this character first showed up in
another hotel room in breaking bad
season 4
episode 2 when walt settled on a snub
nose revolver
lawson shows up exactly twice in both of
the series
and only meets with walt and bb and mike
in bcs
there are three of those recurring side
characters in season two
first there's stephanie doswell who
first appeared in breaking bad in season
4
episode 3 where she brought marie spree
of open house thievery to an end
she popped back up in episode 7 of bcs
season 2 as the realtor who was showing
stacy and mike the house that she
eventually moved into
next we have officer saxton he showed up
at the white house when skyler called
the cops on walt when he wouldn't leave
in the premiere episode of better call
saul season 2
he arrives at price's place after he
calls the police about his baseball
cards getting stolen
finally we have fran the waitress from
loyola's family restaurant
we first saw her serve mike and lydia in
breaking bad season 5 episode 2
where she knew mike's name signaling
that they were familiar
and better call saul she first appears
in the fifth episode of the second
season
when hector comes in to speak with mike
i already mentioned gus's return in
season 3 and in that
same period victor and tyrus reappear
victor first showed up in the mandala
episode of breaking bad
and both of his first appearances happen
in the same episode where gus first
appears though they don't share scenes
tyrus doesn't enter the breaking bad
story until season 4
episode 2 when he takes victor's place
after he's
killed a few days after that he shows up
at the super lab to monitor the cooking
he makes his debut and better call saul
in the third episode of season three
escorting gus and victor to meet mike
for the first time
the characters meet in a remote area
where gus convinces mike to stop
trying to kill hector because he doesn't
want him dead yet juan balsa
and don elattio also make their first
appearances in better call saul in the
third season
in episode four there's a flashback to
ellario's hacienda in 1999.
there we see hector get upstaged by
balsa when he brings a bigger tribute
from
gus with eladio's reaction further
infuriating him
juan balsa first showed up in the third
episode of season three of breaking bad
where he brought the character tortuga a
present of a tortoise for his birthday
of course when he paints ola dea on its
shell it becomes apparent that he knows
tortuga has been talking
and as we're realizing that the cousins
come in and chop his head off with a
machete
don eladio's breaking bad debut wasn't
until the eighth episode of season four
and it's another flashback this time to
1989.
in that we see gus's introduction to the
cartel with his partner max
with elattio don hector and juan balsa
in attendance
in that meeting hector kills max and as
he's forcing gus to watch him die
he tells him that he's only letting him
live because they know who he really
is this of course is a reference to
gus's mysterious
past eladio is an interesting case
considering the influence he has on the
story he only appears on screen
twice in each of the series once in
flashback
and once in the present timeline of
course the second breaking bad episode
he's in is the character's end
and in the very next episode we meet the
next crossover character dr barry
goodman
who's waiting at a secret facility to
take care of gus
after he made his move against the
cartel dr barry first appears and better
call saul in episode 3 of the third
season
when mike heads to mexico and meets him
at his office
the doctor provides mike with the coke
he uses in his elaborate plan to get
hector's truck seized at the border
to round out the cartel side of things
in season three
in episode six lydia makes her bcs debut
this is one of the briefest return
scenes in the series as she's waiting in
the car for gus as he goes to look at
the future side of the underground super
lab
as they get ready to leave she says
exactly three words
in her breaking bad debut scene and the
second episode of season five she says
even less
she actually doesn't say anything when
major girl is meeting with the dea
later we do see her meet with mike at
the restaurant where we see her come
prepared with her
own stevia packets which in the end will
be her downfall
on a lighter note we meet a much more
pleasant version of francesca and bcs
season 3 episode 2.
despite coming from a job working at the
dmv
she seems to be a great find for the new
wechsler-mcgill
office and jimmy hires her on the spot
we don't get to know her well when we
first meet her in saul's debut episode
in breaking bad
but it's pretty apparent that her time
at the strip mall office and possibly
something else
have drained that pleasantness from her
personality
there's also that strange comment saul
makes about her booty as she's walking
out of the office
this has been somewhat perplexing for
fans after getting to know jimmy's
personality in the prequel
francesca also plays a role in the
reintroduction of the final return
character in season three when she goes
out into the hall to bring huel babino
into the courtroom in one of my
all-time favorite better call saul
episodes chicanery
of course we'd already seen him show up
bumping into chuck on the stairs to
plant the cell phone battery
we first saw huel on screen in the
premiere episode of breaking bad season
4. from there he becomes a regular in
saul's story
and he brings to mind the character
patrick qb
these two work together a lot and qb is
one of the characters that's yet to make
a return
although i think the part that steven
ogg played in season 5 was written for
him
only bill burr wasn't available to
reprise the role
the fourth season to better call saul
only has a few characters that return
nick was a part of gus's security team
in breaking bad
he makes a couple of appearances in that
series with the first coming in season 4
episode
7. he doesn't last long in his run there
though
and better call saul nick first appears
in the second episode of the fourth
season
in a blink and you'd miss him situation
where he's holding a gun on
nacho as the season continues he has
several other appearances
the other two return character scenes in
this season come in the third
episode something beautiful first we
have ira who we met as the owner of
vamanos pest in the third
episode of breaking bad season five in
his better call
saul debut he's hired by jimmy to steal
the hummel figurine from mr neff's
office
while he's stuck there we get another
reference to walt throwing the pizza on
the roof of his house
to get that shot the crew had to use a
pie that wasn't pre-sliced
fans noticed that and it led to a big
discussion for why walt would have
bought a pizza like that
the writers addressed this in the next
season when badger tells jesse that they
don't cut their pizzas
and pass the savings on to you in bcs
when neff orders his pizza we hear him
confirm on the phone that he wants it
pre-sliced and when it arrives we see
the boxes the same it's from venezia's
gail bettiker is the second return
character in this episode
he first appeared in the sixth episode
of breaking bad's third season
in a short stint as walt's new assistant
in the super lab
he pretty much got the short end of the
stick at every turn in the original
series
so it was nice to see him return in bcs
when gus needed his expertise
the first returning character in the
most recent fifth season
is a special one edgal braith aka
ed the disappearer is one of only two
characters that have shown up in
breaking bad
better call saul and the el camino movie
up into this point
do you know who the other one is ed
didn't make his breaking bad debut
until the penultimate episode of that
series and he only showed up in that one
episode
his services were mentioned several
times before that but we only see him in
granite state
he plays a considerable role in el
camino which is some of the last acting
work he did as he lost his battle with
brain cancer and passed away
on the same day the movie was released
he does appear
in the better call saul season 5 teaser
when he gets a call from gene
after he gets spooked by jeff the cab
driver they were able to pull this
off by shooting his bcs scene during the
filming of el camino
the timing of this turned out to be a
lucky break for the prequel series
because even before his passing they
thought it might be too difficult to
rebuild the vacuum cleaner store
and fly him to albuquerque for just that
phone call
he probably wouldn't have shown up on
screen in the fifth season if it didn't
play out this way
so rest in peace to robert forrester
there are two minor characters that
return in season five although
the first jody nichols was portrayed by
two different actors in her appearances
she debuted in breaking bad way back in
the seventh episode of the first season
as the realtor who was trying to sell
jessie's house and better call saul the
new actor played the character as she
was holding an open house that jimmy and
kim visit
in the second episode we also saw the
return of detective tim roberts
he had his breaking bad debut in the
second episode of the second
season investigating walt's
disappearance
in bcs he makes his debut in episode 6
of season 5
after mike makes sure some evidence
about lalo's car lands on his desk
peter shuler is a character that had a
short but memorable arc in the second
episode of the fifth season of breaking
bad he goes from taste testing sauces to
committing suicide by shocking himself
with an automated external defibrillator
he accomplished this by sticking one end
in his mouth and one over his heart
and after he hits the deck that toilet
keeps auto flushing
we see him in happier times in a meeting
of important people from madrigal's
restaurant chains later he meets with
gus and lydia in a hotel room where
there's reference to a time in santiago
where their backs were against the wall
this connects peter to gus's mysterious
past in chile
and may hint that we could learn more
about that in saul's final season
probably the most anticipated character
returns in the fifth season were hank
schrader and steve gomez
hank and gomi made their debut in the
pilot of the original series
and in that first episode they took walt
on a ride along
that made a bus that involved jesse and
emilio
when they make their return and better
call saul we see how crazy8 became one
of their snitches
and how that was all set up by lalo and
that
of course sets things in motion to come
full circle as crazy 8 is the one who
gave them that
tip that led to the bust in breaking
bad's pilot years later
and speaking of full circle that brings
us to the last crossover character the
man with the mustache
he made a couple of appearances in
season 2 and season 4
breaking bad apparently he knew the
actor that played gomi
and he got the job that way but where i
remembered him from was the 10th episode
of season 5
as hank walks past him sitting at a desk
in his office and you can get a good
look at the mustache
he makes his bcs debut in episode 504
as hank's congratulating his men on
their bust at the money drops
that is all 35 of the breaking bad
characters that appear and better call
saul
through the first five seasons i'll just
mention
that lalo and ignacio aka nacho were
mentioned
but never appeared in breaking bad so
they don't make the list
we still have one 13-episode season to
go
which will probably be starting in early
2022
the question i'll leave you with is
which characters are you hoping to see
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
i'll be doing more better call solve
videos before season 6
gets here and we'll be doing multiple
weekly videos like i did last season
while it's airing
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon